I hope many of you have used a net took
before or network analysis and I hope to
make the talk a bit interactive because
night to Cal is a very small small
package is more library but i think is
great potential the potential is not in
the library itself but isn't the people
that will use it and so I want to maybe
at some point to learn some of your
stories about the network oh do you use
network and how this package can be
useful on what are you doing ok so and
before we start how many of you have
used network analysis or package like
network ax I grab yes blue horizon ok
perfect so you know what the network is
nodes and links this project started i'm
doing i'm finishing my PhD in Motz in
queen mary but he started together with
startup network which is a small company
i created in italy and this is not
updated is now one year and three month
old but actually I working on it just
for for Fremont is tiny free on the line
of code at the moment I'm the only and
developer of it but there are some
people in in Queen maraan startup
networking and the performance are good
they helped to save memory mainly and to
do computation on time barring graph in
a very small amount of time with
computation is around 70 second I will
tell you more details so let's start
from the first part of the of the name
network so network is a can be
represented as a graph you have nodes
and edges and these are a useful model
to represent many real world system we
use it for representing the brain took
the transportation system like the tube
or communication system the nodes are
the system elements the neurons in the
case of the brain and the synopsis
represent the links
or in the case of the underground system
the tube station and the connection
between them and the thing you do with
network analysis I think many of you
have done something like this you try to
rank nodes tourists and try to
understand which is the most important
note the most critical no Dina
communication system you try to
understand if your network is resilient
to attack or is fault tolerant and
usually you rank No you say you do some
analysis on this graph and at the top of
the ranking you have the most important
note the most influential people on
Twitter for instance with which is the
most famous rank have you seen sure is a
google pagerank and they just take all
their web pages which represent the
nodes and there is a link between to web
pages if there is a HTTP is the risk
HTTP connection h is billing and and
they do some mods on on this graph and
there are many Python libraries is
specialized on doing this kind of
analysis you can compute google pagerank
with Metro Tech's graph tools I graph
and also snap which is from Stanford was
ever use of the snap no one ever look is
quite it's quite fast Stanford
University URL a scotch and the the
thing that is changing in the last year
is the fact that Network change over
time evolved over time it's not that you
have just one single graph you do the
computation and that's it you have your
ranking if you take the Twitter the
Twitter graph at any second in time it
changed so you have new connection
created or destroyed forreston from 12
to 11
you have this link that disappear this
link that disappear and you may want to
recompute the google pagerank of other
quantities in all this graph and if the
network is largest big is is complicated
if we can take sometimes and if you want
to have high resolution in time the time
of the computation could be could exceed
the time of the update of the graph so
you can keep update your ranking in real
time has the network change so this is a
general problem of course you can rely
on big infrastructure cloud computing I
have as you see a small 22 from 2009
macbook which has been upgraded but
still as 8 gigabyte of RAM and I like to
do everything with with him I also
remember that people went to the moon
with something that was much less
powerful than this and when you have
this perspective when you change
prospect you start to understand the
problem try to make the algorithms and
the thing more efficient instead of
relying on huge expensive infrastructure
and it's possible to do this and I don't
focus on google pagerank I think the guy
in Google much better than the mean
updating this graph but I focus on
distances which is a building block of
many other measure if you have ever
heard about closeness centrality or
information centrality a lot of measure
a lot of ranks apart from the google
pagerank are based on distances and the
distance is a graph is just the number
of ops between two notes so the two red
nodes here i have distance 6 because
there are six links connecting them and
at point t plus 1 a new nodes arriving
in the network and the distance between
the two red node reduces so now is one
two three
you want to update this number from six
to three and you don't want to recompute
all the distance because he's basically
and useful you can notice that some
distance between some groups of nodes
are not affected for instance the green
one the distance between this guy and
this guy is one and doesn't change when
you had this new links and it's the same
from all the other all the other green
nodes and it's not something new
actually something I mean you can build
algorithm that update only the the
distance which actually change after the
introduction of new hedges and avoid to
recompute distance life this one from
this guide to descry one two three four
and this distance doesn't change so why
you need to recompute it is just a waste
of computational power and time so
ramalingam reps from Microsoft Research
did a nice peppery in 1996 which is
called on the computational complexity
of dynamic graph problem so the dynamics
here is devolution in time and there is
a nice algorithm which has been used
also recently but it has been used many
on huge infrastructure because this
algorithm needs to store at any point in
time all the distance with all the
distances between any two nodes so this
is the genetic matrix or distance matrix
and the number six for instance is the
this distance between the two red nodes
and that point t plus 1 number six
becomes free what the algorithm does
just change those number that needs to
be changed while all the other remain
the same so the algorithm takes as input
this this matrix the new hatch and try
to minimize the computation okay
the the whole grid needs to access all
the distance at any point in time and
the problem is that in large graph you
have many many distance scale us n
square because there are n times and
nodes and recently there is in this work
made facebook which they tried to
compute all the distances between the
average distance from you and any other
people in the network which is similar
to computing all the distance between
any pair of nodes and actually is quite
big the facebook graph and they didn't
compute all of them they did some
statistical analysis of all the distance
and the number which provides which they
provides you on on this web page is an
estimate it is a good estimate for this
huge large large graph they use
infrastructure or framework like apache
europe which takes billion of nodes in
the computation the interesting thing
okay we have a problem here we want to
recompute in time but we have this huge
amount of numbers we have to store
somewhere if you we put them on on a
cluster they are spread all across
different computer and if we want to
retreat them we have to have these
numbers and these data are going and
flowing on on the cluster and it's not
super efficient there is something if
you look on the web page there is a
chart which I didn't have the internet
connection before so I try to reproduce
reproduce it it's not like this but this
similar and it said that the number of
note the percentage of nodes with a
certain distance the frisson between
iodine NJ is pick the owner septum value
the majority of pairs of node f distance
equal to 4 or free is what they say here
right free and not degree of separation
or other we are free oops enough
distance from we have a free or enough
distance from each other
the distribution of distance is
something that looks like like this a
great majority of numbers in the matrix
are all the same okay and the idea of
network al is to have a look at the
matrix spot which is the number with
which is more frequent and remove it
from the from the runty this is the
first step so what I use in a circle are
two concept I will introduce them one is
the sparse genetic matrix which usually
on your graph helps to save fifty
percent of memory and the sparse be
connected geodetic matrix which can save
up to seventy-five percent there are
graph in which i only need twenty-five
percent of the memory which you need
with the full marks and here is the idea
let's take a s'more a s'more graph
example graph the one there so the
numbers are the notes the they are
connected through these gray links and
for the moment don't pay attention to
the red blue and green circle okay just
think of this graph of eight nodes and
what the usual genetic matrix is you
compute all the distance and is there n
times n memory the sparse genetic matrix
consider looks in this in this approach
we search for the most frequent number
from most frequent distance in this case
is number one and we just removed from
from the from the matrix and you save
some memory disease implemented at the
moment in network allows a dictionary
which gives you back number one whatever
the key is missing so you have a d of IJ
if the pair RJ is not in the dictionary
representing the matter you get number
one as a result II don't get nervous
this graph is that in general does it
supplies you can yeah you can consider
just I mean it doesn't work at the
moment the library on disconnected graph
but you can end all the time use them
separately analyze them separately
because the if they are distribution you
know that's really imagine if you
introduce a new head connects them i
will show you what happened with the be
connected approach and in when you have
to disconnect the component they looks
like two blocks in the matrix and once
you connect them with a link you have to
fill up the off diagonal part of the
block can you visualize it if you have
two components they are like two matrix
in the two independent matrix and once
you connect them through once you
connect the two component with a link
you have to fill up if you put together
the two matrix in the diagonal you have
to fill up the empty and empty part yeah
there is not because of see how do you
if the graph is disconnected will have
several false they see me representing
you know disconnected distances with
nothing I will show you I will try to
remove link between four and five and
let's see a sample in a second so okay
spartamatrix you save some memory just
removing this quite simple it's not huge
the second thing is try to do what is
called be connected the composition of a
graph in the be connected decomposition
you identify sub region of the graph sub
graph which have the property to be be
connected component I will not go too
much into the detail but basically is
that you can't split the graph in two
parts removing just one node within the
component
so in the be connected component the
composition you identify in this graph
free be connected the components which
are the green the blue and the red one
and in the be connected component the
composition you have special nodes which
are called articulation point which are
number four and number five these are
the only two nodes and in the in the
graph which can disconnect the graph in
different components so if you remove
for you get two groups if you remove
five you get two components if you
remove number six no the number six you
don't break the entire graph in to come
and disconnected component that is
always about doing any other nodes okay
once you do this the composition you
realize that any distance any path from
one node in the green group and one node
in the red group have to cross the
articulation points so if i want to go
from number one to number eight i have
to cross number four and number five if
I have to go from number free to number
eight from number 22 number eight I have
always to cross to pass by number four
or number five it means that once i have
the distance between number let's say
three two or one to number four i can
reconstruct the distance to number eight
because i can compute it as a distance
from five to eight so i can compute the
distance from one to eight as a
composition of the distance from one to
the articulation point of each component
go through the link between the two
component and then from five which is an
articulation point to number eight okay
you see you can see this here you
construct what it is called block cut
three and it tells you that any nodes in
the first component
have a path through a note any other
nodes in another component must go
through number four and number five if
you realize this you understand that you
don't need to store the distance from
one to eight from two to eight and so on
you can just store the distance the
distance is within a be connected
component is that clear any questions
the block cut tree is a tree so as no
loop so once you you have two nodes
which are in two component there is only
one one part that connect them you can
go through multiple different activation
point but there are no loop so there are
not two there are not the only one path
between them so it's like you have only
one bridge in in the river on the river
in times so any distance and short the
spot you compute with google map from
the south part of London the north part
of lon us to go through the bridge so
you don't need to store all the distance
from the south to the north you can
store all the distance from any part on
the south to the bridge and from the
bridge to any other part on the north
side is that clear is a bit tricky and
I'm from a multi-part land so you could
have said something like this so when
once you do this you don't need to store
the distance from the green groups to
the red group it means that you can
avoid to save this part of the matrix
yes
if you were to build the full Judas it
mate matrix what yes sir what's the
complexity of the jock star greet me is
a number of nodes time number of links
plus number of nodes number of Link's
log of number of nodes if I'm correct no
n Square log n Square log n plus n K and
K are the links so it's a square square
complexity at least I think what you
want to do is you try you know slice
sure yes and in the end yes because they
want the processor is fast but the
memory more than eight is illegal to put
eight ego buttons section I mean
officially takes for this one but I
would date he works but more than this I
can't the I'm trying to really do the
computation on facebook on the Facebook
up on this i will show you that play is
maybe was wearing one year we will
manage to ok i saved this part I don't
need to store the distance from the
green to the red node so column one is
node one row eight is node eight and you
see that there is an empty space in
position 18 because i don't need the
distance 18 I can reconstruct this
distance and once I have this I can look
for the most frequent number in each
component as I did for the sparse
genetic matrix so I construct what I
call the sparse be connected to the
single matrix I look at component one
and they say oh look the number which is
which appear a lot of time is number one
I save it only once you know in a
variable and the dictionary which
represent this part of the matrix will
return me one well all the time I ask
the distance from is from one from node
1 to node 2
I don't need to store this directory and
starting from eight time eight square
matrix I need only eight plus four
entries and a representation of the
block cut tree which is a huge saving
this is a small example but I did some
tests i will show you some tests on them
unreal network some from the full matrix
you realize you look at the structure of
the graph and you realize that this is
just a huge waste of memory okay no
distance of edge length not only length
1 it works for binary network so if you
have a weight on the on the link you can
do the specification because only I mean
you if they are if there are three or
four classes of distances you can remove
the most frequent one but if you have a
weight on on the hedge which is the
distance between two node the length of
the hedges 0.3 another one is zero point
31 is most more difficult to find a very
frequent distance but for binary network
it works for any number actually in this
example the most frequent one is number
one but in real network is three or five
which is the usual diameter of any large
large graph okay how much time do I have
because my cool
five more minutes okay okay I okay this
is the way you reconstruct the distance
from instant from node 1 to node 8
basically you follow you follow the the
block cut tree and you some you some the
value on this on this pop and here is
let's test network let's test it here a
couple of graph this is not the entire
facebook graph it just a smaller sample
they are around the 20,000 20,000 nodes
and if you under percent represent the
full the full matrix and times and
entries if you use the specification you
get you can reduce up to fifty percent
fifty percent of the of the distances
have the same value which is three or
four if you use just the be connected
decomposition you can go down to thirty
forty percent what is nice for this
network wiki boat thing is taken from
Wikipedia if you use the sparse we
connect the genetic matrix you go down
to twenty percent so eighty percent of
all the henrys in the matrix are just
just a waste of memory yes as well the
properties of the graphs that caused the
vine connected decomposition to increase
say oh that's the sparse duties and so
saying end so into the grass the
facebook one in there astrophysics one
yes The Bone Collector decomposition
is more than the sparse on learning is
really mine Ted by connected the
composition is from the main from the
story wrong so it's less than a percent
for everything they're two different I
didn't get the Western very what you say
from Astro physics and Facebook and
Facebook and you say that this parts
were connected it's like you have more
space and spas no but this is not as
approachable net weather was not using
up more physical this is the amount are
you left yes i know i am wondering
there's a reason why the only other
seems like there's a water ok ok ok you
see that the ordering is different ok ok
ok i was trying to compare the two and
they didn't get the fine you can also
say the same thing for one you just
saying that the gray dark gray is lower
than the light gray yes this is the
point ok sorry i didn't get it i was
trying to compare them the answer is I
don't know and now I we thought about
this but the moment as it came to him
and plug and it depends it depends on
the structure it depends on the
structure and on the on the way you wear
or not all be connected the composition
are the same so you can have a huge
block cut tree or a small-block country
and sometimes you may have also just one
very large by connected component which
contains 99% of the nodes and in this
case there is no ask service already
kind of particular had a growth trimming
or something you could
frankly an answer it's very unusual for
you to their one person had none of
their friends and they know none of your
friends which is what the biokinetic
decomposition is doing is trying to find
that one link between two fully
connected graphs yeah I was this is a
very small sample taken from somewhere I
don't know where less than than 20 it
doesn't know for sure I don't know what
that what's the structure the by
connected the composition of a facebook
case but it would be interesting to to
explore this any other way it's linear
time while distances are computed in n
Square log n back and neck is a
composition you can complete the linear
time if the graph change annually you
know reconstructed matrix is quite quick
to do
just like reconstructed by connected
there are some trade off is a research
I'm doing this is the potential in
saving then you have to unreal setting
understand all the all the trade-off it
also depends if a lot of money you put
on the classroom from there okay so this
is nice and if you have around I mean I
hope to this can be even lower if this
goes down to ten percent you can do on a
seven gigabyte RAM computer like this
what you are used to do on a 75 gigabyte
cluster so if i reduce to ten percent 75
18 is one of the machine was using in
the facebook experiment if you go down
to ten percent you can reduce to
something which is more similar to this
one it's a big challenge i'm not saying
is something i will do tomorrow okay
this is how it works I to do this test I
had to develop something so i wrote this
free on the line of codes for the
research and then it's okay maybe I
should put on the github given it works
and may be useful for other people so
this is the how it works at the moment
but i hope you will change soon and now
this is what you get so you import
network at us and out and you can use
this function if you start from a graph
which has already some nodes and that
just you create the spur the sparse
distance matrix and you store in a
variable then you pick some some nodes
let's say five and seven and you ask an
ethical to update the distance matrix
and you have to provide the graph the
sparse distance inj and if you want to
add or remove this edge and it will
update this here it will change those
not only those number who needs to be
changed so we can do a quick test maybe
i have here off by the nodal book I hope
it works okay can you see it I'm just
importing the library and I create here
where it should be bigger okay okay this
is just the import like right here are
at the training graph of a thousand
nodes is a random graph and I called the
sparse distance metric function which
just do the standard computation of this
of all the distance in this graph so if
we execute this is Network axis better
net effect which is not the fastest but
this is nice to do experiment and it
takes some time is computing all the
distances between all pair of nodes in
this thousand nodes graph and it takes
18 seconds now here I just create some
hundred the random pair of nodes so this
is just a list
just a list of of pairs so these are
links which I want to create in in my
graph some of them may be already
existing so for instance i want to add
the new link between nodes 204 and nodes
under 66 and for each IJ for each new
edge i use the function update distance
matrix and with mode addition so it will
add all these edges and for each one of
them it takes some milliseconds ok you
can start from an empty graph and not
edge one by one and reconstruct the food
graph but the the saving is is quite
quite big and it's just really
experiment added in a couple of months
free month last year it was working well
it has been tested so for each new link
had that I was computing there with the
standard algorithm the full matrix and I
was checking all entries one by one I
did this several several time just to be
sure that what I implemented was was
right so the one is on the github you
can fully trust and lets it basically we
use it I mean I know it's not for we use
it this thing for in the company how do
i go back here we use this thing in the
company because we compute distances in
what I call the worldwide network of
start up this is what the company's is
analyzing and we compute all the
distance between any companies in the
nectar can we try to find successful
companies to predict success so we want
to compute distance between let's say
how far a police from what's up how far
yahoo is from what's up that white
clothes off
uber is from the White House and this is
quite close David Bluff is the guy who
did the Obama campaign election campaign
so when they have all the problem with
legislation friends at the White House
cannot and we explored we explored this
graph we compute all these distances and
on the graph we see how company moves to
the center or the periphery and we use
this to predict success Airbnb was
moving very fast to the center close to
Google Facebook and you can find this
computation online and this network
efficiency is basically closeness
centrality which is based on distances
in is a matrix of network analysis based
on distances and that's it I mean time
there were some questions ready me since
you had already a few questions within
the talk we only have time for a couple
more you would say some memory by
eliminating the diagonal zeros and it's
not is not till jure but I thought about
this actually you can I mean yeah you
can if you inside them the class which
defines all these free type of matrix
you check if I NJ are the same but since
you are removing some already some notes
you have to check manually the tie NJ
are the same a return at zero in this
case otherwise if you just remove them
and you ask distance I I you will get
the one again
I sure sure if if you somatic you can
you but it doesn't change this result
because this is under the percent full
if you divide it by you can do this also
in the full matrix so you divide by two
this number and this number so it
doesn't reduce more than this this is
Vicki road I don't know you usually have
this huge folder with the many many data
set then withdrawn now I think it is a
network of people voting up and down
some article on wikipedia some should be
something like this I haven't used on
these are all undirected so I don't know
if if you put a directed graph which is
an object in net to text if it works it
may be because it is just function like
the neighbor of and the neighbor should
followed light should consider the
direction of the graph in the link but
I'm not sure in period of course there
are great when the system it works if
it's directed this is not symmetric the
matrixes are not symmetric so in
principle is of course it's feasible I
don't know if you can plug directly a
directed graph on torkoal at the moment
I think that's it thank you